[Music]
is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 percent discount on
a wide range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
so i wanted to make this video really to
show how joel rogan has been deciding to
put
guests on his show talking about islam
who have this very particular
bias perspective against islam one of
those individuals is majid nawaz
now majid nawaz is a reformer in his own
words but in reality
he is seen by a large part of the muslim
community in the uk and abroad in the
west generally
as a clandestine apostate from islam
so what happened is i some time ago
actually done a poll on my channel
and obviously my channel is quite big in
terms of muslim representation
and obviously relatively quite big
almost 10 000 people replied to the poll
as you can see on the screen now 60
percent almost 60 percent 58 to be exact
of people classified this man
to be a clandestine apostate 22 percent
of people
saw him as an ignoramus unqualified to
talk about now
this is the kind of individual who gets
about 80
to 85 percent of people who
are surveyed at random and anonymously
because quite frankly these polls are
not
uh completely frivolous in terms of
sociological information
they can grant us certain advantages
that wouldn't be afforded
through demand characteristics and other
things when people are actually
interviewed
to face 80 to 85 percent of people
think this man is either a disbeliever a
closet apostate
who is too scared and who is too
uh much of a puss animus too much of a
possible animus to come forward
and declare his apostasy and 22 percent
who don't believe this believe that this
man
is a rank ignoramus so this is the kind
of individual
you're bringing on the show and on the
show
he makes a few statements which i find
quite
questionable so let's see the first
thing that he says
a professional polling company found
that zero percent of british muslims
responded to a poll saying that they
found homosexuality morally acceptable
and then a year later which now last
year another poll uh was uh was
conducted
i think it was roughly 52 52 if my
memory serves incorrectly said
of british muslims said that they would
uh wish for homosexuality to be
criminalized
so he talks about these polls and for
the most part when he's when he's
referencing polls he doesn't actually
cite the source sometimes he does and
sometimes he doesn't he says zero
percent found it morally acceptable
my question is so what
so what isn't that part of freedom of
speech and expression religion
if muslim people decide not to find
homosexuality
morally acceptable or they find it as a
moral aberration
how is that in any way shape or form
harmful from a harm principle
perspective
to other people are these muslims that
saying that are saying that
homosexuality and they mean by the
practice
the penetrative rectal penetration
of a man to another man they find that
for some
reason or another morally apprehensible
or aberrational
those individuals somehow need to be
reformed
so if that is the case why didn't joe
rogan himself
have the guts to question ben shapiro
who he put on his show
who we know is a is a practicing jew and
in his constituency
i think we're going to find especially
in orthodox areas a very similar
kind of demographic in terms of
accepting
or lack thereof in this case of
homosexual practices but why even go
there
when in your own country 33 of people
don't think society even should accept
homosexuality according to pew research
which is
seen as the gold standard of research in
the united states of america
33 percent and if you look at all the
other countries
especially in sub-saharan africa 90 to
of people in sub-saharan africa even in
countries which are majority christians
do not think homosexuality is
morally acceptable so why don't you
bring this
discourse to the african sirens because
you're afraid
that you will be called a racist
you are afraid you will be called a
racist why doesn't joe rogan
put an african on and tell them how
africa needs to affor
uh reform itself sub-saharan africa let
the white man come in again
as he did in the past with his guns
and his religion yeah to tell the black
man what to do
90 to 98 of countries like kenya
of nigeria many of which are not even
muslim majority like kenya's not a
muslim majority country
do not believe that homosexuality is
acceptable
and believe you me if you ask them about
what should we do with homosexuals you
will find
even more even though they are
christians even more severe things that
you'll find for muslims in the west
bring a black man on and ask him those
questions you coward
and tell him to reform african culture
let the white man tell the black man to
do that again
but you bring this coconut this uncle
tom
this uh traitor of the muslim community
called majid nawaz who i
publicly challenged to debate but he
like a cowering
scrounger a ruffian decided like a
puzzle animus that he is to scurry along
and put his tail between his legs and
run away even though yes my platform is
bigger than his
and yes i'm more educated than him in
terms of qualifications what excuse did
he have
oh this guy was not influential in his
community clearly that is not an excuse
or this guy is not as qualified to my
level actually i probably have double
the degrees that he has
oh this guy doesn't know islamic jewish
prudence actually i have been trained in
that area
what excuse do you have majored now as
for running away in this way
and you know full well who i am because
you mentioned
me in your tweets and you've blocked me
and my associates alidawah and zishan
smile to jannah you block them because
you are afraid
and a coward and this is what we're
seeing from people now
you joe rogan just have your little echo
chamber bring these people on
and all that shows is that you have an
agenda against muslim people
when was the last time you brought a
reformed jew to talk about the jewish
community
in the same way as this man is talking
about the muslim community
you wouldn't do that because you don't
want to pick a fight with the jews
and you wouldn't do that with black
people because you don't want to pick a
fight with black people
but muslims are fair game for you we're
not easy meat
you would not want us in the
intellectual octagon
you're afraid all of you are afraid
quite frankly
and our voices are becoming too loud for
you to ignore
and you know what i was going to speak
about some of the things that this
individual
called majid nawaz mentioned
as in one part of his segment there when
he was talking about charlie hebdo
and trying to link that with muslim
attitude citing no source whatsoever
a quarter of british muslims when asked
about the massacre
at the charlie hebdo offices in paris a
quarter said that those attacks are
justifiable when we know that muslims
even according to pew the vast majority
of muslims the vast majority of muslims
around the world
condemn terrorism and terroristic
behavior but you're trying to paint
a particular picture of conservative or
traditionalist muslims
devoid of intellectual integrity devoid
of academic credibility and devoid
of credibility in any way
is what you are so joe rogan is
is the case that you're a closet
islamophobe instead of
interviewing these people that you agree
with why don't
when you're holding the microphone like
a chaperone for khabib and for uh islam
and for anclev and for all of these
muslims that you
have to hold the the microphone for why
don't you challenge them
they're the traditionalist muslims why
don't you challenge them on islam why'd
you have to bring a guy that agrees with
you
i find this to be honest with you quite
distasteful
and for a man who who prides himself on
courage and martial arts
i i'm really quite surprised that you're
in the position that you are right now
but still yet i will offer my services
still yet yes i offer my services to
bring you out of the situation that
you're in
the pathetic situation that you're in
where you and your guests have nothing
but cognitive bias and are producing
nothing but
a loud echo chamber of anti-islamic
apologetics
and all you have to do is send me an
email
and believe you me if you don't it
doesn't matter
because by refuting you in four five
six seven videos on my channel i've
already raked up
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
views so you keep talking and we'll keep
refuting
to